Transformers!
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Welcome...Tinhead?
Who you calling Tinhead?
Hello, hello, hello!
Minkitron!
Yeah,
meet those in disguise.
It's time for Optimus Pride!
I love Transformers, like the transforming sound effect.
Teacup!
It's your birthday!
I was wondering if you could sing MGS5 birthday song.
This is my first MGS game.
Please forgive my sins.
Sins of the teacup.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Teacup!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the P!
Hope you have a great birthday.
Mito Minto is a Transformer.
What would I transform into?
I would wanna be a flying type Transformer.
Probably.
Or like a sick bike, maybe.
I probably would be like a tricycle.
Everybody makes fun of poor Trike Mike.
That guy, all he does is transform into a tricycle.
Only babies ride him.
Who invited Trike Mike to the squad?
Who invited that guy?
Cursed Mickey Mouse toaster.
Like Starscream.
You can transform into Metal Gear!
Oh my gosh, so true.
There is a tricycle Transformer toy they sold in the 80s.
No way, seriously?
I foretold the past?
I fore... I saw it.
I saw into the past.
Transformers.
Curious, have you seen the 86 movie?
I have not.
Actually, I don't think I've seen really any of the movies.
Minus like the Michael Bay ones, but those don't count.
Probably.
Though, I will say that Megatron at like the Universal Parks is so funny.
I like watching videos of him because he's just... Actually, I've met him before.
Do a watchalong?
We should!
We should, we should.
I always cry watching the 86 movie.
I've seen Transformers 1.
I talked about that on stream before recently.
I've watched it a couple times now.
And recently I've been watching Transformers Prime.
Because that's free!
On YouTube, if you didn't know.
It's on... You can just watch it.
They have the series.
All the episodes.
On... on... on... on YouTube.
So, yeah, if you're like, oh, I want to watch a show.
Oh my gosh!
I'm not very far into it at all.
Like, I've literally only... I started it!
I like watched the first episode.
And then some family stuff happened.
And then Valentine's, I started working on it.
So I literally just was like...
And then I watched episode 2 last night.
And oh my god!
The... the... the... what's it called?
The Unicron blood stuff and the zombie...
The zombie transform... Oh my gosh, it's so good.
It's so cool.
Mega Mint.
Dark Energon!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, it's so good.
It's so cool.
Unicron is dope.
But yeah, so I'm like, you know...
This game came out...
I think around the time that I was watching Beast Wars.
So I was like, oh yeah, Transformers!
Yeah!
And I never ended up playing it.
I never ended up playing it and...
Now it's delisted.
So... yippee.
Good job, Past Me.
Actually, I looked it up.
Because I was just like, I know it's delisted.
I looked it up earlier today.
I was like, I wonder how much this costs.
To like, try and get like a physical copy of it.
On Amazon, it's like $200!
For this game!
$200!
What the heck?
It's like, it's like trying to get...
Rule of Rose or something.
Craziness.
Crazy, crazy.
The devs of Metal Gear Rising made this game.
That is correct.
This is a Platinum Games game.
So...
I think though, that this game is a little bit more like...
Devil May Cry?
If I understand correctly.
In terms of like, you run around and then...
People show up and you're like...
So, I have to warn you guys though.
More like Bayonetta.
Oh, see, I haven't played Bayonetta yet, so...
But I have to warn you guys today.
Oh my gosh, I did not sleep well.
At all.
And I had to wake up early because I had some early morning haunting stuff to do.
So...
Just heads up.
When I put this on my schedule, I was just like...
Oh, I can probably one stream it.
But we'll just have to see.
Oh god, I'm already yawning.
We'll just have to see.
I had to like, peel myself off a chair.
I was like, just sitting there.
I was like, okay, I gotta go stream.
I gotta go stream.
So...
Yeah, but if I don't finish it, I'll probably honestly just...
Play it tomorrow.
We'll see if I wake up from it.
I also have some coal for you.
A lot of the cast from the 80s cartoon reprised their roles for this game.
Really?
The most notable exception being Starscream and Wheelie Jack's VA, Chris Slotta, who passed away in 1994.
If you were to become a Transformer, what kind of vehicle would you transform into?
I wanna be like a fighter jet.
That's what I want to be in my soul.
But I feel that I would be...
A shopping cart!
Oh my gosh, I'd just transform into...
I'd transform into like a Omurice.
With wheels.
What if I could become Metal Gear?
What if I could transform into Metal Gear?
Metal Gear Rex.
As a Canadian, I just need to say...
Beasties.
Beast Wars is my favorite Transformers.
Yes.
I... Oh my gosh.
Megatron in that series made me a Decepticon fan.
100%.
So...
So, you know...
It's kind of hard to...
But...
I do love...
I do love the Autobots though.
We're gonna be playing as the Autobots, obviously.
Oh yeah, the Predacons.
Yeah, yeah, the Predacons!
Sorry, I always forget that.
Like, technically...
Like...
Like, aren't the actual Transformer guys...
An actual Megatron, like, dead in that series.
So good though.
Predacons.
Yeah, Beast Wars is in the future.
I should rewatch it.
But it's hard to find it.
I don't think there's anywhere you can...
Legally watch it, I think.
At the moment.
I watched it on Netflix a long, long time ago.
So...
Like I said, it was like 10 years ago.
About when I...
When I...
It's on Tubi!
YouTube has it?
Really?
Okay.
Beast Wars is on Tubi!
Tubi!
It's not on WubWub.
It's not on Woobaloo.
It's not on BlingBong.
You're gonna watch it on Tubi?
That was my birthday yesterday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course!
You can just call me Jellybean.
Jellybean!
Okay, glad.
Because your name actually cuts off.
So all I could see was...
The asexual.
I couldn't see any other part of your name!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Jellybean!
The asexual.
Why
is my controller so warm?
It was against my cup!
Oh my goodness.
It's like, why is my controller so hot?
Oh my god.
You guys have been watching stuff about the new graphics card?
Oh my gosh.
I'm kind of glad I didn't wait for the 5090 or whatever.
Holy moly!
I mean though, I couldn't buy the merch last night unfortunately.
Because it doesn't ship to my country.
No, I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry.
I see so many people saying that it doesn't ship to their country.
And I got help on this one from a different place.
So...
So hopefully in the future...
Hopefully in the future I can find a way to expand to more countries.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so, so sorry.
The mugs are all sold out?
No way.
The 5090 has serious wire issues.
Yes, yes, yes!
That's what I've been watching!
I've been watching gamers...
I watch Gamers Nexus and stuff like that.
That channel.
And I've been watching...
I can't remember the guy that I watched.
Last night.
But...
He's like...
German?
Some...
I think?
And...
Germa.
No.
I could not tell you the name.
But he was like getting out like a...
What's it called?
Oh my gosh.
A...
A thermometer.
And he was like...
He was like...
Filming the...
The wires and stuff with the thermometer.
And showing how hot...
Just one wire...
Like the power distribution is all crazy!
It's so...
I was just like...
Oh my goodness.
Why did I think of that?
What made me think of that?
I don't remember.
I don't know why I brought that up.
Oh, my hot controller!
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Like I said, you guys.
My brain is a little bit mushy.
But yeah, the power distribution for the wires just doesn't seem very...
Great.
And...
It could...
Potentially...
Ruin your...
It could burn your...
Your graphics card.
But, you know.
So, I'm glad that I didn't even attempt.
Not that I don't...
I don't think I would have been able to get one anyway.
I am Mint Frantum and I send this message to any surviving ghost taking refuge among the afterlife.
We are here.
We are waiting.
Can we get your best Megatron?
Oh, wait.
Give my best Megatron...
Yes.
No.
Pretty good?
Perfect?
Will you be playing the new Yakuza pirate game?
Good luck with the games today.
Thank you.
I...
I don't know because I've never played any of the other Yakuza.
So, I don't know if it's something that I...
Could play.
It seems pretty like a...
Like a...
Off...
Set of games.
So...
It seems like maybe it doesn't have a lot of stuff.
Like...
Rather...
Like it's not a mainline game.
So...
I know.
You guys don't need to tell me twice to play Yakuza.
You don't need to tell me twice.
I've been really wanting to play it.
The only...
I actually brought this up on stream before.
Is...
You know, I was just like...
I really want to play Yakuza.
But so many other VTubers have played it recently.
That I feel that maybe there is a bit of a...
What's the word?
Like a fatigue.
About it.
So I'm thinking maybe...
In the future.
Like give it some time to kind of...
Have people be like...
Oh, I'm kind of pining for some more Yakuza.
It's like, you know, Yakuza...
I think it feels so saturated.
Because it's like such a long game.
It's a long series and a long game.
Like each one.
So it's kind of like...
You see so...
Even though it's not everybody playing it, right?
But...
You see it so often come into your timeline maybe.
Depending on who you follow or something.
You know what I mean?
So...
That's kind of where I'm at.
But after...
Devil May Cry, I'll be...
After Devil May Cry is I'm doing Ace Combat.
So...
And then...
After Ace Combat, we'll probably go...
Maybe then I can at least do one Yakuza game.
I felt that with FF7 Rebirth.
I mean like for me...
I think it really just depends.
For me, I get so excited to see anyone playing Metal Gear.
But I can understand from a viewer's point of view.
If you are not interested in Metal Gear...
It would be like...
Everybody...
There are so many people playing Metal Gear.
I don't care.
Where am I?
I want to just watch something.
So...
Everyone loves Metal Gear.
I love Metal Gear.
I made my birthday with yesterday.
Ender Preston, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Ender Preston.
Happy birthday!
So I try to like...
You know, I don't want to...
I don't want to burn anybody out on...
On games, you know?
Alan Wake?
Yes, I have that.
I have been wanting to play that.
Especially because I want to play two.
Maybe we can...
That's only two games.
Maybe we can start that soon.
Reminds me so much of the original Xbox 360 and its overheating issues.
I had one that literally melted the aftermarket fans.
That you could plug in the back.
The plug was melted in the power cable.
That's so scary.
I worry so much because...
Like, you know...
That's kind of like such a big fear of mine.
Even though I'm a ghost, I'm a collector.
And...
Some things I collect are more dead than me.
You know?
And so, if I...
You know, if there was to be like some sort of fire issue...
It's one of my biggest fears ever.
So scary.
So be safe, everybody.
I hope that if you...
Did get one of the new graphics...
If you're one of the ten people that got one of the new graphics cards...
You...
Have no issues.
So...
I don't know why people keep recommending it to me.
It doesn't sound like...
It sounds so lame.
Bad.
Wow.
I saw someone say earlier too.
I think it was a super chat that...
What?
Like Xenomorph?
I'm not like...
You know, I don't know everything about computers, but I try to at least...
You know, this is...
I mean, having a computer is part of my job.
So I try to stay updated on stuff.
Predator, not Xenomorph.
Sorry, sorry.
Anyway, I'd add control with Alan Wake.
All of Remedy Games are connected, but these two are a little more connected.
Okay.
I'll try to remember that.
The only downside for this game is that you can't play as any of the fembots.
No!
I'm so excited.
You know, we might...
I don't know.
I know that this...
I think this game...
is pretty short.
But there are like side missions from what I remember.
So...
I don't know.
We'll see what happens.
We'll see what we do.
Story mode, obviously.
Commander!
I remember movies because of Megan Fox.
I did not watch because of Megan Fox.
I watched because of the Transformers.
We are two different types of horny.
I am horny for the robots.
I think you are horny for the women.
Not that I'm not too, but...
We are not the same.
For me, I think robots...
Robots maybe sometimes dominate the women.
Well, I wish they would.
But you know what I mean.
Let's say we are ranking.
Like, robot women are probably at my very...
I love...
Okay, guys.
I don't think...
Okay, have you guys ever watched Fireball?
Fireball is this...
I'll say old now.
It's pretty old now.
But it's an old Disney animated short series...
That features this robot girl named Drossel.
Look her up...
And you will understand 100% my type of robot girl.
And it's so funny because...
I went to a convention not too long ago.
I say that.
Actually, it was...
Maybe a couple of years ago now.
But there was a table selling doujinshi.
And I was just like looking through.
I was browsing.
I was like...
And then I see one.
And I was like...
This robot looks so much like Drossel.
And the guy that was manning the booth...
He was just like...
You know who Drossel is?
And I was like...
I know who Drossel is.
Nobody knows who Drossel is.
Oh my gosh.
Yes, Jenny.
XJ9 from Teenage Robot.
She was one of my...
She was one of my first crushes.
I love her.
Oh my god.
Her?
Drossel?
They're so perfect.
Yes!
She looked like Miku a little.
True, yeah.
I love robot girls.
I don't think I can express that enough.
But the doujin that I bought...
The guy was just like...
Yeah, actually...
This artist loves Fireball.
Loves Drossel.
And so that's why he based these characters kind of off of her design.
I joined in on an interesting conversation.
It's all related.
This is all robots.
Thoughts on Dorothy from Big O.
I love Dorothy.
I mean, she's very human, but she's...
You know, humanoid.
But she's so, so cute.
Oh, she's so cute.
Grew up during G1.
This game was a nostalgia trip.
Platinum Games knocked it out of the park.
Platinum Games...
I feel has a good track record.
You can correct me if I'm wrong though.
I'm glad we are in good company.
I'm glad we are in good company that we like robots.
They are cute and also hot.
They are cool and cute and hot.
Oh,
controversial opinion, really?
Blackarachnia.
They lost everyone lately.
No way, seriously.
Oh no.
They turned out so many licensed games.
Not many of them were as good as this one.
That's understandable.
I guess maybe because I'm like...
Bayonetta.
Metal Gear Rising.
Apparently, this is really good.
So, I'm like...
Okay, Platinum.
Okay.
They sucked a lot recently.
No.
That's like one of the worst things, right?
When your...
When like a...
Company...
Lives long enough to become the villain.
Kind of...
Idea, you know?
Where it's just like...
If only they could just put out something like they did before.
Anyway.
Okay, I've yapped for 30 minutes now.
I'm kind of...
Oh, guys.
I don't know.
I don't usually play easy mode, though.
But I'm so seepy today that I'm feeling like maybe I should.
Especially if it's like a...
I don't know.
Do you think I would be okay with Warrior?
I think I would be okay with a Warrior.
The Eepers.
I am so eepy seepy today.
You're a...
Lowish?
I'm a loser?
I'm a Louise?
What?
Blackarachnia did reveal to me I have a type.
Go with Warrior.
Go for Scout.
It's about the action anyway.
Easy mode is fine.
I think...
You guys know me.
Usually I would play on normal mode.
But I think today I just can't do it.
I'm sorry.
I'm weak.
So, you can flame me in the comments.
It's okay.
I give you the allowance.
Say, this ghost played on easy mode.
Not a gamer.
Wow.
New York!
Oh no!
I would love you even if you were a Worm Bot.
I hope people weren't in those cars.
Insecticons?
I love...
As soon as Starscream starts talking you know it's him.
Oh yeah!
Constructicons!
Starscream...
Soundwave the goat.
Get that sweet, sweet Energon.
That's me in the back!
lol
Also sorry, I don't know all their names or anything like that so...
Please forgive me.
Deceptichops.
Yeah!
It's a really empty building.
The pain and the fear.
No way!
Autobots, I'm fine.
Autobots, I'm good.
I'm good.
Move character, rotate camera.
Wow!
It looks so cool!
Oh my gosh.
Autobots, I'm good.
I'm gonna start...I'm gonna start referring to you guys like...
I'm gonna start being like...
Wisps, I'm good.
Lift!
Lift?
Let's jump.
That's not throw.
Lift and throw!
Throw!
Wait, lift?
Oh my gosh, yeah let's go.
Wheeljack, come in.
Is this Cybertronian technology?
I think so, Optimus.
They're creating hurricane force winds like they're trying to sweep the city clear.
Whatever their purpose, there is more to the situation than meets the eye.
Sorry.
I'm not gonna be this obnoxious, don't worry.
He said the thing!
Oh, whoops.
Lift and destroy!
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
What else can I destroy?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
And then this is...
Okay, circle does nothing by itself.
So it's like an interact kind of button.
I really like cute girl characters who are cocky, pathetic, silly losers.
Despite being a straight man, I love Starscream for those same reasons.
Understandable.
Oh, indestructible tree.
Oh, just kidding.
Can I destroy the cars too?
Oh, Starscream.
Always trying to one-up Megatron.
He's such like a...
He's such a weasel.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, they're tiny.
Okay.
Oh, R1.
Vehicle attack.
What's square?
Square?
Oh, hey!
When you see a blue flash during a combo, quickly press R1 to perform a devastating vehicle attack.
Oh, there's more of them?
Uh...
Oh,
square?
Square?
They're looking different.
That's gonna be me one day.
Seeker.
They're so cool.
How do I shoot from them?
Oh, L2?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
I'm out!
I think I get more...
I think I'm out of stuff.
Oh, he's dead.
Hello!
Oh, he's dead too.
I'm not doing anything, am I?
Yeah!
You guys can't see my rank, but I got an M for Minto.
One shall... One shall stand.
One shall fall.
While ground troops are created just for this game, their design are based off of Decepticon twins, Runabout and Runamuck from the original cartoon.
Collect Energon cubes to restore your energy.
Green cubes will restore health, while blue cubes will restore your weapon's energy.
I see.
I don't...
Who am I fighting with?
Who are you?
Oh,
now that's how you throw.
Look at that.
Now we learn.
Side swipe.
Oh, thank you.
Toss down.
Hit.
OK.
Set down.
You go on ahead.
OK.
See ya.
Oh, what's this?
Energon cubes.
Attack this Kion barrier repeatedly in a short time to destroy it.
Then you may proceed.
Oh, what?
I did it anyway.
MintoCharm, would you describe us as having the touch and the power or that we dare to be stupid?
I don't understand this reference.
Probably dare to be stupid.
We're all a little stupid, right?
What's this thing?
Can I throw something at it?
Throw!
Come on, Optimus.
Don't miss.
I give up.
Is that Bumblebee?
You know what?
Whatever works.
Bumblebee!
Hold R1 to switch between robot and vehicle modes.
Also he talks.
I can't believe you are playing this.
The music on the boss fights is absolute fire.
Go Minto Prime!
Oops, sorry.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Wait, hold on.
I can't stop.
I can't stop drifting.
Help!
Give me help!
I can't stop!
I can't stop drifting!
Oh my god.
What is this?
After jumping in robot mode, you can change form midair to perform a ground slam that will damage enemies and unearth buried items.
Now I can't do it.
I did it!
Thank you.
Thanks Bumblebee.
Nothing beats a ground pound.
True.
That's what that...
First try.
Met Michael Bell, VA for Sideswipe at a con years ago and he hinted at being involved in this game before it had even been announced.
It was quite a treat to hear many of the original VAs back again.
I bet this is such a great nostalgia trip for so many people.
How do I use the different weapons?
Wait!
Can I go back?
No!
I didn't realize I needed to hit this thing earlier.
Search?
Hit this trans-spatial converter to materialize and hit an item.
Dang.
Oh well.
Hello.
Dodge using R1 just before an enemy attacks with it.
Focus state and briefly slow down time.
First donut!
Thank you!
I haven't watched the 1986 Transformers movie yet.
We'll do a watch along though.
Maybe I should have done that before this stream.
What we could do is if I...
Is if I don't finish today...
We could...
Holy shit.
Oh shoot.
I didn't dodge soon enough.
Dodge!
Vehicle attack!
You're welcome.
I know he's already dead but...
Warning!
We got him.
What are you doing?
That's not what I meant to do.
I meant to do this.
How do I... Oh, here we go.
And you too.
I got it.
I can't aim.
I'm out again?
Can I get up there?
Oh, I can probably from here.
New figures based on it are coming out this year.
Seriously?
My timing is impeccable.
What's L3R3?
That's new.
Dodge.
I'm all charged up and I don't know what...
What?
Oh, sorry.
Where?
No, no, no, no.
You
need fire for that.
Shoot it?
But I'm out.
It's my birthday tomorrow but I'll be VOD gang for the next few weeks.
And I was hoping you could try singing in a southern bell accent.
I can try.
Will it be good?
That's a different question, but I can attempt.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Liquid Toast.
Happy birthday and come back soon.
Happy birthday!
No!
Oh my God.
Run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away, run away.
Grab!
Oh, grab.
Underdog!
Grab Underdog.
OK.
You know what?
That works.
Shoot.
I dodged.
I wonder...
Nice!
Not this time.
I'm out.
Shoot.
Can I...
I wish I could like... Maybe I could just attack his feet.
I'm dodging.
I'm attacking your feet.
Get your toes.
Oh no!
Don't say that.
I still have like...
Ah, shoot.
What was that?
This one.
Finishing attack!
Nice.
It's so cool.
A bumblebee!
When did this happen?
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
I'm punching.
Oh, he's got... He is.
Wait, what's his...
Oh, whoops.
Game
owns!
Oh my god!
What's so great is they move so smoothly.
They move so smoothly.
Like the transformation and everything.
Like it feels so natural.
God!
Wow!
Can I handle this one yet?
What am I doing wrong?
He's gonna bumbleblast.
Is this also... Oh yeah, he also.
I wasted it.
Oh well.
Take them out how?
How do you want me to what what?
Find cover and take them out?
Oh, change weapon is this.
Oh, now they tell me.
This one maybe?
Oh, ok, ok.
It's hard to control that.
Wow, I got an A!
Wait, so...
What else we got?
Basic machine gun, Bumblebee's gloves.
How do I change my...
Wait, where is it?
We got it.
Let's go to other inventories.
Autobots, roll out!
I love the transform sound.
What the heck is this?
Pick up.
Oh, Kremzeek!
I unlocked new stage art.
Kremzeek!
Cyber form.
I keep hitting the wrong thing.
Where is that?
And then...
Got it.
Ranged Uncommon.
Should I go this way?
I know it tells me to go this way, but what's over here?
I love exploring in games.
Have you seen Transformers 1?
I have!
Ah!
I think I made a mistake.
Where was I coming from?
Nevermind, just kidding.
Sniper wolf.
I see, I see what I need to do.
I'm still trying to get used to the controls.
There is no way this way.
Just kidding.
Holy moly, fast.
So I do need to...
We
made it.
Ouch.
Oh gosh, oh my god, oh my god, he's so fast.
I tried, I tried to move.
Ok, it's always like the same spot as it seems.
I tried dodging, I did.
I did.
I see, I'm too slow though.
Ok, I'm too slow.
Or rather, I was fast that one time.
Ok, that seems to be our ramp.
Is there anything else over here?
Oh, we cannot go this way yet.
Too windy.
I think we can take it.
Who pays for the damages?
The citizens?
The autobots?
How do they explain this to the citizens?
Yeah, sorry for the mess.
Oh shoot.
Sorry for the mess everybody.
I'm looking for hidden collectibles.
Mystery object.
Megatron!
What is the meaning of this?
Optimus!
Come to save the day, I presume?
I am here to stop you from destroying the city.
Stop me!
Oh Prime!
You have no idea what you're really up against, do you?
Who is really behind this?
What?
This is our home now, Megatron.
We should respect it.
No matter, Prime.
I have no interest in destroying Earth.
But I'm not opposed to making a few, shall we say, improvements.
Follow me.
You've got to break through Megatron's shield.
To perform a rush attack, reach max speed in vehicle mode and use the melee attack button.
How do I...
We're driving, we're driving.
Not
enough!
How do I know if I'm going max speed?
How do I know?
Optimus!
Optimus, how do I know?
That's not enough!
I think we did it.
Oh my god!
Oh
my...
Max speed!
We dodge that like a gamer, true pro.
Oh gosh!
He hits so hard.
Ouchie ouch!
Oh my god!
Where are you?
That was my fault.
I pressed circle instead of square.
I'm an idiot.
Couldn't get me this time!
That was so close!
That's my next trick.
Taking out the trash!
Yeah!
Like I said, it feels so smooth to transform and everything.
He's talking to me!
Me!
Move out!
He's talking to me!
Megatron and Soundwave are voiced by the OG.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
That's what people were saying a lot of the OG people came back.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh gosh, I'm not as fast as Bumblebee was.
Oh my god!
I don't think I got all of them!
Where did it unlock?
Up there!
I see it.
Bumblebee was so easy to maneuver.
Yay!
What weapons do we have?
Flare gun!
Basic missiles.
Flare gun.
Thank you guys for all the superchats!
Sorry, this is a tricky type of game too.
Come to see them, because I'm like running around and doing so much stuff.
So I apologize.
Sushi!
Oh my god!
Starscream!
I didn't realize the superchat was from Starscream.
What the?
What do you mean failure?
Maybe I need to be a basic missile.
Nope.
Do I need to drive through?
Car mode didn't work either you guys!
Everybody sounds so confident.
Do I need to...
Am I just going the wrong way?
Maybe I need to go this way.
No, that's not...
The max speed...
Let's try that.
I'll do a little lap.
Our engines...
Thanks Optimus!
See ya!
Ok!
Thank you!
Jump!
Nice!
Did I get everything?
Can I jump again?
Jump!
My depth perception...
It even... Come on!
Just drop.
Maybe I need to do it again here too.
Nice!
Ok, so if it's that kind of...
So we're heading that way.
We can't go that way, but...
Nothing there.
We're here!
How's the volume by the way?
Sorry that I'm kind of late asking.
What if I transform?
What if I went really fast?
Each character has a unique ability that can be performed by pressing L1.
Deplete the ability gauge, but this gauge refills over time.
Well...
Kick their butts!
And we're gonna go...
Where did he go?
Ok!
I missed.
Anyway...
Good job!
We did it.
Very nice.
Five big booms.
It's good?
Ok, thank you.
Oh, ok!
Thanks Optimus!
Look, there's stuff over here.
I can't leave yet.
There's goodies.
Oh my gosh!
Optimus Prime is covering me!
How lucky.
Lucky for us.
What's this way?
This looks kind of fun.
What is this?
Here we go!
I'm on a racetrack all of a sudden.
I hope I don't die here.
What?
Oh!
Enter?
I'm trying to click enter!
I'm too fast.
Oh, side mission!
Let's try it.
It's our first side mission, so...
Defeat all enemies!
What was this ability?
I think it's a rush attack or something?
Oh, that was...
Blackhead!
Oh, I had another one.
Where's the goal?
Over here?
They're shooting at me!
I didn't get it.
No!
See ya!
I reached the goal.
I did not defeat all enemies.
Oh, shoot.
There's Harker.
Oh,
dang.
Loser!
Did I get all the guys?
I guess so.
No?
Is this not the...
Red dot?
Oh, I think I see them.
We
got 30 seconds!
Oh no!
There's more?
Where?
Guys,
we're not gonna make it.
So lame!
I thought those were just like, you know, like little turrets or something.
I didn't realize that they were...
I didn't realize that they were actual guys.
Dang.
Fish and mailed.
Did we get to keep all the stuff though?
I think so.
Look at the little bugs.
Little buggies.
What would we get if we beat the mission though?
You can repeat?
You can?
Let's see.
I don't plan on doing all the side missions, so...
Like, you know, just to...
Just as like, if it's just like, oh I missed one, it's okay.
I just really wanted to try this one since it's the first one, right?
We can get cool weapons.
I always miss the second...
Let's get our stuff.
Let's get our things.
I don't actually know what all this stuff is, so...
Slice and dice, baby!
Maybe I should be in vehicle mode right now, but that's okay!
Bam!
And where are these guys at?
Oh, secret...
Oop!
Bam!
We'll just run here through here for now.
Slow, slow, slow, slow.
And bam!
The auto-lock is so great.
Thank you, auto-lock.
I like how I can lift him up.
It's kind of awesome.
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
Did I get them all now?
Ah, there's more!
Where did you guys spawn from?
There we go.
I just don't know how to...
Change the weapons.
I'm getting these new weapons and I don't even know what to do with them.
Anyway.
Optimus is gone.
He's got tired of waiting for me.
After mission.
What is this?
Okay.
Do I want to... No, I'm just gonna run.
Okay, now I can just...
Nevermind.
Will they have... Dang shields.
You guys, I got an S rank!
Oh my gosh, I've been consistently getting B's, but with that I got an S.
Yeah!
Which way should I be going?
No, no, no.
Well, I think I can do...
What's the ground pound?
I was just being a little silly about it.
Follow the orange dot.
Yeah, but what's over here?
What is that?
Oh, you want me to be...
That's okay, I'll loop around it.
Dang it.
Drive through it.
Maybe... Hold on, let's go high speed.
Oh, wait.
Oh, just kidding.
That's nothing.
Okay.
Where am I?
See ya!
Give me all this crazy train!
What was I attacking anyway?
It was trying to attack me.
Holy shit, it's a...
Glove!
Claw!
The claw!
And I was out of that range.
I'm not fast enough.
I need to be faster.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Got him.
Punch it.
Yeah, but I like to shoot.
Where are we anyway?
We're explorers.
Sorry guys, I love exploring in games.
I don't know if you noticed.
I'm always... You can't keep me on one path.
Watch the pain.
Oh gosh!
Ah, dammit.
This game is so crazy.
I won't even open the door in the meantime.
Minky the Explorer.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
I'm dumbing down.
Too windy for robots.
Oh
what?
I pressed square?
There we go.
Where are we?
I'm definitely gonna get lost.
I'm gonna get lost, aren't I?
Okay, let's go to the point that we were supposed to go to.
Parking.
No parking!
I'm gonna get mega lost.
Megatron mega lost.
Uh oh, what's going on up there?
That don't look good.
The fastest thing ever.
I don't like what's going on up there.
I don't like what's going on up here.
They're just attacking the building for what?
What are you attacking the building for?
Oops.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Man.
Auto aim is so generous.
Left this building in particular.
I am going the right way though.
Where's the next guy?
We shall become a car.
Oh no, I'm a car and I can't jump over buildings.
I will become a car.
And I will drive!
Drive!
Oh, okay.
And I think that's one last guy.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Am I out of bullets?
No?
I just missed?
Maybe he blew up my...
I got the guy over there.
There's one more.
Oh, I wish I could see through here.
Oh, he's up there, he's up there.
I think we got him.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Made a miso.
Yeah, but that's like Mr. Donuts.
Misudo.
Misudo is Mr. Donuts.
Pegaburger combo.
For 650!
You guys!
Look at... That might be the best deal I've ever seen in my entire afterlife.
A steal!
1984.
Old game.
Megaburger.
Megatron?
Everything mega is better.
If evil, why cool.
Who am I fighting?
Oh, there they are.
I can hide.
Oh my god.
I didn't make it through.
They're waiting to ambush me.
Am I on the right path?
I think so.
I think I must be.
I thought I saw something shiny over here.
Just kidding.
Her name was Megato and she wasn't so short.
That's what I'm saying!
Inflation comes for us all?
Even a 5 dollar foot long?
Don't say that.
You know what inflation will never come for?
The Costco hotdog.
Oh gosh, I can't!
Oh, I missed!
Nevermind.
I still got him.
I'm too good at this.
I think I got him.
Where am I?
Oh, this guy.
Oh my goodness.
Shoot.
Ok, hold on.
There's two of them?
Damn it.
See, I'm too slow if I...
I'm slow.
Ok, nice.
I got one.
You don't need to shoot every time.
I do!
In fact, watch me!
I will be fired.
This one is going to be tricky.
Just kidding.
It wasn't tricky at all.
I'm too good at the game!
Now I'm scared.
Where
are you, cowards?
Come back!
Stream snipe.
Costco hotdog sponsorship.
Oh yeah, they totally...
That's the wrong button.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm so cool!
Aren't I?
Aren't I so cool?
Did you see that?
I got his stuff.
Was there anything else over here I missed?
I don't think so.
Oh, uh...
There was like some guy.
You know, whatever.
I don't care about him.
Too cool for school?
No.
And you shouldn't be too cool for school either.
Hotdog.
Roll for Costco hotdogs.
Somehow directing them.
Costco glizzy stream.
Oh my god, he's hacking!
He's downloading the information.
Oh my god!
The ambulance!
The whambulance is coming to pick him up!
Oh, I will be followed.
OK!
I'm guessing those are bombs so I won't touch them.
Pass through plasma accelerators?
Oh!
To gain speed.
Oh, OK, those are...
Oh, OK, OK, the plasma accelerators are the little...OK, OK, the barriers.
Oh, shoot.
Right.
We're good.
Oh my god, I can't see!
I'm on your butt.
I'm on your ass, Megatron.
Megatron, Megatron, I'm like right on your ass.
Megatron, Megatron.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I can fire at him.
Oh, the R1!
I'm such an idiot.
I thought it was L1.
Which wouldn't make much sense because...
Bye, Megatron!
I'm better than you!
I'm faster than you!
Where are you?
Oh my god, there you are.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch.
Where did he
go?
Oh, he's faster now.
How did he get so fast?
He's a literal tank.
Where did he go?
Oh, am I?
Am I?
Ouch.
Wrong way!
Oh no!
Scooby Doo moment.
They knew that would happen though.
They had you loop.
Oh gosh!
Oh shoot.
That was not good.
Get beat!
Oh
shoot, damn.
I tried to dodge.
Oh, that's his...
Damn, I shouldn't have dodged that.
Take that Megatron!
Oh damn, he really did take that.
Get blasted.
He took that.
Side swipe.
This game is so fun.
It plays so well.
Even when I can't see what's going on.
No,
I don't want to...
Roll out!
Alright, fine.
I shut down three sub-generators.
I've transformed and I'm rolling out.
What's that green?
What's this green?
Too fast for my own good.
Green!
Green?
I thought it froze for a second.
I was kind of scared.
Lightning gloves.
Twin steel swords.
Lightning machine gun.
Basic missiles.
Cryo gloves.
Everything is ranked D though.
Cryo hammer.
C!
Cryo machine gun.
Thermal sword.
D for damn good.
Shock sniper rifle.
Lightning sword.
Raiden.
SWC Ronin, thank you for the pink!
Mecha made me into a model someday would be amazing.
I think Ayamimama would probably kill me.
She'd be like, I don't have control of that.
Maybe I would have to commission somebody more mecha inclined.
If Megatron was walking through the parks and got attacked by 10 pigeons, who do you think would win?
Megatron is equipped with a chicken sandwich.
What is this?
Why do people keep talking about this chicken sandwich?
And the pigeons.
Where did this come from?
Wow, we got a lot of weapons, didn't we?
Rare!
Oh my gosh.
Hyper lightning hammer.
I want the lightning hammer.
Is it slow?
No, this is the cryo hammer.
This one.
Now you can have the option to change characters.
Use L2 or R2 to choose which character you'd like to play as.
Oh, what?
Oh my gosh.
I could be Sideswipe.
I could be Optimus.
I like Bumblebee.
Playing as Bumblebee though.
I'm glad you like the long hair.
So if I give him... Can he... Did it say that he could equip it?
I didn't see.
It showed me who.
His gloves.
Oh, he can.
Only Optimus can.
It looks like.
Oh man.
What else do I have that's rank C?
Prime's axe.
Nah, it's too big for him.
He's just a teeny baby.
Oh, this.
The shock blaster.
We could try it.
I do like playing as Bumblebee because he's super nimble.
Look at him.
He's so chill.
What a chill guy.
I'm Bumblebee.
Oh my gosh, he can talk.
That's right.
Ever since Michael Bay, they made Bumblebee unspeaking.
Except in Transformers 1.
He's just a little baby.
Everyone copy that from Bay.
Stinky.
I like his character a lot though in Transformers 1.
He's not like... Usually I find that maybe those types of characters can be a little too much.
But he's not too much I think.
He's just the right amount of annoyingly funny.
Badass dread.
He's just right.
If he were any more, I think it would have been a push too far.
But I think he's just goofy.
OK, let's try it.
Equip and develop tech?
No way.
Oh my gosh, is there like a skill tree?
Or is it Minecraft?
What are we building?
Nothing apparently.
Nevermind.
We have nothing to make.
Neither does sideswipe.
Megatron must be stopped.
Stopped.
What are we waiting for?
Oh yeah, he's thinking.
Ready, ready, ready.
Follow me.
Must be stopped.
He's putting on his thinking hat.
OK.
Oh wait, I have to develop stuff first.
I'm a dummy-dum.
5000.
Equip.
Let's do another one.
Not the skill check though.
There's lag.
What is this?
Weapon energy recovers gradually.
Melee attack up.
Yeah, whatever.
I'll do one more.
Is the ping, is the ping?
My finger slipped.
It's never my fault you guys.
I don't know what to tell you.
It's never my fault.
But that was all me baby!
Ally heal.
It's never my fault until I do well!
Do I need to save this stuff for like other...
No!
What an absolute failure!
OK.
I hope I don't have to save this money for something else.
First try.
Lag for sure.
Wait, so let's equip.
Let's get rid of that one.
What was the good one we did?
This one.
And then, enhance radar.
Shows hidden treasure on the minimap.
Wheelie Jack and Sideswipe cameo as cogless miners in TF1.
They do!
Wheelie Jack is the one who accidentally triggers the mine cave-in at the start of the movie.
I'll have to watch it again!
Came for the robot stage from MitoTron.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you for the first ever.
Glad you stayed alive.
OK.
No moves!
Oh my gosh.
Bye?
Bye, bye, bye!
Oh!
That's what our money is for!
OK guys, I just wasted all of our money.
Grimlock's gloves!
Oh, dang it!
Why did you guys stop me?
OK, anyway.
Let's try... Wait, I can change the difficulty through here?
Wow, that's so nice!
I feel really comfortable playing it like this though.
I'm having a lot of fun.
Sorry I'm a little scout.
I'm a girl scout.
Find the sub-generator.
That's right.
That's what we were doing.
Is there one in here?
Oh gosh, that's kind of spooky.
What is this?
Wait.
No, no, no!
That's his new ability!
It shows us where hidden things are!
Oh my gosh.
Very nice.
We can't go this way.
That's where we came from anyway.
And there is a thing over here.
Actual ground pan.
We are going to be rich.
I hope so.
Use your fists.
Alright, I guess we have to go into the scary hole.
I hope that person had insurance.
There are bugs in here!
Oh!
Take that, dummy bozo!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Where did the other guy go?
He is literally hiding behind that wall.
You see him?
What are you doing over there?
Maybe he won't notice me.
What?
Oh, I think he is stuck by the wind.
Stupid.
Can I hurt the bugs?
Bugs!
They don't notice us?
Yeah, I'm still going to kill them though.
I'm too good!
What the hell is that?
You scared the heck out of me.
Gosh.
Thanks for playing this.
It's awesome to see one of my favorite streamers experiencing one of my favorite franchises.
If you were a maximal Predacon, what would your beast mode be?
That's a great question.
I think I got everything in there.
I don't know.
Frog?
Monkey?
Oh my gosh, it would have to be a monkey, right?
Nice.
Thank you.
I think it has to be a monkey.
Minky.
Minky type.
Alright, so there is one right there.
Auto jerk.
Oh no, the constructed guys.
He is so fantastic.
Let's see how you Autobots look on my hook.
Holy fast.
OK.
They are huge.
Damn it.
I could not see where they were.
Oh my God.
Why didn't I dodge?
Oh shoot.
Hello?
Oh my God.
Auto jerk is my best.
Too easy.
Says the guy who couldn't even land a hit.
Punched him right out of transformation.
I
keep missing the vehicle.
Oh shoot.
I thought I dodged.
I dodged too early.
These guys are so beefy.
OK.
One down.
Nice.
Come on.
I was...
Are you OK Bumblebee?
Nice.
He is almost there.
Jeez.
I love the dodge going into car mode.
It's so awesome.
OK.
What if I... Oh I don't think... Oh I have to search it?
Let's see.
Oh gosh.
I think I'm going to need to...
Oh.
Never mind.
I thought I needed to break in.
OK.
I might need to take a second.
Thanks Optimus.
I'm going to go grab some eye drops really quick because my eyes are like...
My ectoplasm must be so dry today.
I don't know why.
I think it's just lack of sleep so my eyes are a little bit...
I know I'm not blinking.
I'm literally like this at the screen.
My eye drops are just in the bathroom so I'll just go grab them real quick.
And then I'll come back.
Be right back.
Like in two seconds.
As soon as I opened the door I got ambushed by a little girl.
Pause.
My kitten pause wanted to be in here.
She's going to want out in like two seconds though.
Let me put in the eye drops.
I don't know why they are hurting so much.
Pause.
Oh my god.
I turned around to look at her and she was already stretched out completely on the floor.
She's one of those types of cats that loves to stick her legs out and her arms out and look like a banana.
She's already a banana on the floor.
Pause.
Well then I'm going to kiss her a little bit.
Little girl.
Sweet baby.
Sweet baby girl.
What are you doing?
You want to sit on my chair?
No?
You want to lick yourself on the ground?
Okay.
She'll probably want out in like a couple minutes so...
That's okay.
Especially because I'm going to be screaming a lot from this game.
Alright.
Let's roll out.
Oh shoot.
I missed it.
Let's try again.
Oh and I even missed the stop.
I missed the goods.
Nice.
Alright we got it.
Right?
Sweet little girl versus stinky boy.
Okay.
Hold on.
She's causing mischief.
Sorry.
She's just chirp-chirping at a bird outside.
Okay.
Where?
Dang it, I missed it.
Ouchie ouch.
Oh I did it.
I'm too good.
If you want to be a transformer fighter jet, ask your art mama to draw you similar to Midia from Gundam Legend.
Oh sorry, not Gundam.
Oh my gosh.
Guardian Legend.
It's old school.
They might not get a headache with that style.
Oh, look into it.
Thank you.
Thanks for the superchat too.
Okay.
Wumblebee.
Let's punch...
Whoa!
Oh,
I dodged too soon.
Gosh.
Please.
There we go.
Alrighty.
We're back to 9000 money.
That's not bad.
Oh it's Wumblebee's L1.
Oh he does a little slide.
That's fun.
Gundam Legend.
Wait, I'm off?
Just kidding.
I didn't want to go that way.
Just...
I'm zooming...through.
Oh, and I missed all of them.
Well, all but one.
Give it in the air!
Holy shit!
Ultimate combo!
I didn't even let him have a chance to breathe.
Didn't even have a chance to breathe.
Stupid dummy.
Gotcha.
Not...Oh, I forgot Wumblebee's...
Wumblebee's, like, missiles are his machine gun.
Took out a Decepticon Spy Ops.
Unlock new scene for the art gallery.
Oh, cool!
There's one more guy though over there.
It's a little unruly.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
What am I hearing?
Just kidding.
Where is this thing?
Can I go through this way?
Maybe.
Sparks and plugs.
Oh, wait.
In here?
Okay, this is where we were gonna go before.
Who's gonna ambush me in here?
Oh, nobody.
Oh my god!
Green
is where we can shop, right?
I'm so lost.
Wait, there's another secret over here.
That we can't get to.
This place is a maze.
Have you heard much about the old comics?
More than meets the eye, I had a lot of Old Man Yaoi and a lot of Neat Megatron.
I'm never... I can't say that I've ever been much of a comic book reader.
I'm too much of a weeaboo, you know?
Where I'm... Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm more of a manga enjoyer myself.
Because you can't read.
Where did you get that idea from?
Oh my god.
Okay, alright.
Dammit, I missed one.
I'm just gonna keep ramming them.
I think I got them.
Wrecked.
Okay, so these did power... I don't think we were able to go in this one before, so...
I forgot.
Okay, I think for these I just have to like...
Just keep going.
Just get out of there.
There we go.
No!
Scavenger.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh!
Look at this pompadour!
I should have dodged that one.
They work the same way as before.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Shit!
Oh my gosh.
He's gone.
Wait, I
think...
Come here, bonk!
Crush it!
Nice!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
Heal!
Oh damn.
Back attack!
Damn, that does a lot of damage.
Nice.
Made Domingo with the devious back shots.
Splattered.
Oh, I think I just lost that money.
Sad.
Maybe you can dodge five times in a row.
Really?
Baby so strong.
Bumblebee.
Oh my gosh, it's the mega burger combo.
Oh shit, they're coming after me again.
Ouch!
Oh, it's this thing again.
Where are you?
Oh, I'm trying.
I'm trying to pick it up.
I'm trying to pick him up.
Pick up!
I'm spamming C.
Circle?
Sorry.
I was thinking C.
Can I not pick up while I'm in there?
I should.
Oh my god.
Pick up!
Pick up my calls!
Please!
Why won't you call me anymore?
He doesn't get low.
Maybe here.
I'm spamming the button.
Is there a spot that I can get to him?
I got him!
Call us back, Crimsy.
I'm scared.
I'm just gonna run.
What's down here?
Interesting.
Not where we need to go though.
More art.
I love the art in this game.
So stylized.
It's great.
This looks like a new area.
Oh, it's right here.
How easy.
You'll have to go through us first.
How strong you're steel, Autobots.
Complete the conquest.
Mix master and long haul.
Back to attack!
Back attack!
Bam!
Oh, he blocked it.
Bumblebee is special.
I think he zooms forward, right?
That was a close one.
Back attack!
I got hit against the invisible wall.
Yeah, that's right.
Where are you?
There you are.
Oh shit!
Yeah, take that!
He's low.
Come here.
Nice zoom.
And a back attack.
Ouchie, ouchie.
So close.
Yeah!
Loot gone.
It's OK.
You're talking about his, right?
Yeah, it's OK.
Don't worry about it.
We'll get more.
Oh yeah, my slide.
Again.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Alrighty.
Uncover the cause of disturbance in the city.
We gotta go back?
Can we not go this way though?
Then we just get rid of this thing?
Holy shit!
Damn.
Never knew it was coming.
Give me more heal.
Yeah!
And my money.
Oh, my money.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't know where we are.
I know we are definitely not on track, but that's OK.
I have no idea where we are.
Oh, we can go that way.
We can go this way.
But how do I get this thing?
Can I shoot it?
I don't want to waste all my bullets.
Shoot at it?
Wait, seriously?
It'll work?
Hold on, what other bullets do I got?
Oh my gosh, my shock blaster.
Heavy attack.
Are you OK?
She went out.
Hold on, let me let my cat out.
Look how cool he is.
Stop!
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
When she wants something, she starts pulling at the curtains.
She does that.
She pulls at the curtains when she wants something.
And then, Butaro also started doing that.
He learned from her.
He didn't use to do that until she started.
That influence indeed.
Alright.
Let's go.
So close.
I can get it.
Wait, where did it go?
No, I did get it.
I'm so good.
Oh, it's back there.
Just kidding.
No.
I almost ran past it.
Not good influence.
Let me out.
Oh, it's this guy again.
OK, we got this.
I'm gonna run out of all my stuff.
I'm trying not to... There we go.
Get my stuff.
Hit him with your ultimate!
Shouldn't I save that?
I guess we could.
Wait, where's my ultimate?
Wow!
Wait, I was thinking of the other one.
I actually didn't know about Bumblebees.
Let's go.
That was crazy.
I'm gonna say Mint is gonna start pulling on the curtains when she wants something.
What are you talking about?
I'm not a cat.
Unless you want me to be.
Do you want me to be?
I guess I could have opened this.
Am I gonna get shot at?
No!
Oops!
Oh, it's these guys.
Bye!
I did this in sub-optimal order apparently.
Since we are having to go all the way over here now.
Oh gosh!
I gotta shoot them.
Oh my god!
Nevermind!
I got one.
Oh shoot.
Grab, grab, grabby, grab, grab!
Grab, grab, grab, grab, grab!
Got him.
I tried to... I pressed... Actually at the same moment I pressed the... What's it called?
The slide.
Oh shoot.
Thank you.
Get our money back.
So if I go over here...
So we could enter here.
I could like switch out characters whenever I feel like it.
That's so awesome.
Or we drive through here.
We have... Oh!
We have an ambush?
I was trying to grab that first.
What was this thing?
Up there.
OK.
Where?
Oh!
Time to vent.
We got it.
Go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Oh there is one here too?
Oh it's... Wait.
It's on the other side?
These guys again.
Oh gosh!
OK.
Let's go.
Again?
We should do that too.
It's the fear.
Oh there!
Megatron!
Oh my god!
Am I all by myself?
What happened to my team?
Where are you guys?
Hello!
Oh shit!
I
did not dodge fast enough.
The music is so insane!
I don't know what weapon I...
Oh my gosh!
Devastator!
It's kind of insane!
OK.
Nice suit.
Oh my god!
OK.
Oh too soon.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Get me out of here!
Holy shit!
I'm punching him!
I'm punching!
And I'm attacking!
Oh no!
Oh damn!
Oh that really hurt!
That really hurt!
Oh my god!
I'm stuck!
Phase 2?
Oh my god, no.
No!
Guys,
I'm in trouble I think.
Oh my
god!
No!
What?
The second phase is gnarly!
Oh they put you at the second phase.
That's so kind of them.
This game owns!
Where is my health at though?
Wowie!
Now I know what to expect.
Oh he's so close though.
I'm out of, I'm out of.
Oh wait, now I got blasters.
Oh shoot.
Oh shit.
Oh gosh!
I don't have anything else!
I'm just punching at this point.
I'm just punching!
Oh my gosh I ran right into his fist.
Oh he's down!
He's down!
Take him out!
Beneath the Earth?
That wasn't so bad actually.
Well, well.
Bye
bye Earth.
Check your heals and boosts and ammo recoveries from the selected prize menu.
I have those?
Oh you guys can see my score.
That's embarrassing.
Yay!
We did chapter one!
How many chapters are there?
C gets degrees.
We got his drills!
Six chapters.
Blasters.
Everybody is saying, you guys don't know anything.
Everybody is saying different stuff.
Everybody is saying something different.
I'm going to look it up myself.
Transformers.
Devastation.
I don't trust the AI over here.
Seven chapters.
Again.
Skip this.
Wheeljack can now be selected as a playable character.
Wait, we have not...
Follow me.
We didn't get to play as him before.
Mechatron must be stopped.
I really do like playing as Bumblebee.
Let's see.
But he is so tiny.
It's hard for weapons for him maybe.
Maybe.
Let's see.
Can you get the...
He can't get the drills though.
He can get the drills though.
Maybe we switch out from the blasters.
Or no.
Will he still be so fast even with the drills?
Run!
Thanks for the fine gift.
Thank you.
Now he is a real Bumblebee.
He's got...
He's got stingers.
I was wondering, who must be stopped again?
Megatron must be stopped.
Cool.
Can we switch out the blasters?
Maybe we get something...
A little... Okay, energon attack.
Let's see.
Okay.
What was that?
It has a better attack power and stuff.
But what's...
This one is overall better in every way.
So let's do that.
I don't think we have anything...
Gosh, look at that thing.
It's craziness.
We could do the...
The twin...
We could actually become Raiden.
Take out the trash.
I think of Naomi.
Maybe we should actually become Raiden.
And then we can get rid of...
The basic machine gun.
And we'll put in the shock blaster.
That should be better.
Synthesize weapons.
I can make even...
Will this level stuff up too?
I wonder.
Because if I really like something...
I'd like to...
Like the drills.
The drills are really good.
We can use it to level up.
Let's just pick something dinky.
Something kind of poopy.
Like this.
I don't know.
Create the weapon shown.
So it just adds to its level, right?
Oh,
and it costs money!
Good to know.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
It didn't really do much.
It didn't even level it up.
That's okay, that's okay.
I just wanted to see what happened.
Attack!
Wait.
No.
What was it?
I think it was like the buy weapons.
So we can synthesize them.
Oh, the lab.
There we go, there we go.
Buy.
Wait, I can also sell stuff for better things.
Yeah, we can sell the dinky stuff.
Every rank D.
Goodbye.
Because I think it's...
Well, we don't get much money from this either.
I wonder what's worth more.
Synthesizing it or selling it.
I watched your stream for the first time today.
I was fascinated by your creativity and cuteness.
Let me support you from Japan.
I'm sorry for my bad English.
No!
Your English is so good!
Misuzu-san, thank you!
I'm happy.
Thank you.
Your English is perfect.
I'm sorry for my bad Japanese.
Thank you.
Timicus Prime, thanks for the super chat!
Okay.
Let's just keep going.
I'll become a bigger brain with this later, maybe.
The music in this game is so good.
Everyone is so nice.
Everybody is so nice.
Good morning!
Okay!
Okay, okay.
That surprised me!
Optimus has thick fingers.
Oh no.
That's me.
On my way!
Oh wait.
Alright.
Was there anything else in here?
Sorry, I just want to check real quick.
It does not seem to be the case.
Can I destroy these?
Okay.
Damn.
I want to try the drills out.
Holy cow.
We already got him.
If you were a transformer, which would you...
I
want to get the stuff.
How much damage...
Oh, okay.
It's not bad at all.
Just a little bit more.
You can charge with a heavy?
No.
Learn, thank you.
Okay.
I went the wrong way.
I didn't notice that there was a...
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
There is a thing down here.
Again?
Wait, didn't we get this one before?
We can get it again?
Over and over again?
We can farm materials.
Let's go.
I'll take it.
And also here.
The drills are very cute.
Farm away.
And we get ambushed here.
By some...
Oh
damn, I totally fumbled that.
I missed the back attack.
The deadliest weapon of all, Minto driving.
You would trust me.
You would trust me as your Uber driver, right?
What do you mean?
Roadkill.
What are these?
Okay.
How do I use my...
Ah!
If I want to use the swords, I can.
If I want to use the drills, I can.
So it's... Okay, okay.
Understand, understand.
Why did I do that?
I'm styling.
Stream and shop 50% off today for snakes and autobots.
If only.
There's no discounts for transformers apparently.
What's the yellow mean?
Oh, it's windy.
That's why.
I see, I see.
I can make it!
Oh!
I can't make it!
Ah!
I should have just shot it.
Is this thing gonna come down?
This thing is scary.
But they give me some... Only 5 bucks.
What the?
Oh my gosh, the seekers.
Seekers.
There's more?
Give me your money.
I got him.
Give me the loot.
Does this game get 5 big booms?
Boom!
Look at you, so chill.
Boom, boom!
Wait, that was 6 big booms.
I think this game deserves 6 big booms.
Information.
Log info.
Nothing over here, right?
There's a different way we can go, but...
Oh my god!
Oh god!
I did not live.
Wait, I need to go back through it.
Go back and...
We booming now?
Someone who beat this game on prime difficulty, I'm happy seeing other people playing this game.
Oh, I'm glad you liked it.
Enjoying the stream?
Keep up the great work!
Thanks GLaDOS!
I appreciate it.
I like how we're just like a little...
Buggy car.
Melee rare.
What are these things?
Yeah, it's...
It's insanity now.
Oh...
Oh, I just realized there was a jumping...
There was a little jumping fire guy earlier and I forgot to grab him afterwards.
Shoot.
He was like, I saw him during a boss fight and I forgot to go back and get him.
That's okay though.
Kremzik, I can't remember their names at all.
Ouch!
Sorry, depth perception.
Where?
He's here!
This is bad.
What the hell?
What did I...
I'm completely out!
Refocus!
Oh, when did I attach the sword?
Where'd it go?
Oh, I see it.
It's passing beneath me.
I need more materials, I think.
Oh shoot.
Sentry boy!
What's his health?
Oh, it's halfway there.
Did I get it?
No.
Dang it.
Okay, that was big damage.
Oh shoot.
We got the door open.
Time to go inside.
Where's the last guy?
Where are you, coward?
Show your face.
Oh, there's three things down here.
He fell down here.
He's gone.
It's my birthday!
Thanks for giving me motivation while I did a bunch of cleaning I've been putting off.
Mr. Frisco, are you working on your birthday?
Not allowed?
Not okay?
Oh no!
Let me sing you happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Mr. Frisco!
There's more of them?
Yah!
Oh wait!
Oh shoot.
I missed my chance.
Yah!
Their drills are really powerful.
Their drills are really good!
Nice dude.
Dude.
Walking into history, are you?
Alright, don't let our stuff despawn now, Bumblebee.
Nice.
Okay.
He ain't even out of breath.
I know!
You're not about to breathe?
Sometimes.
Woo!
Ranged unclamoring!
They have pistons.
Repair kit.
What was... Someone said like... Not main menu.
But I have like healing items and stuff like that?
Select?
This is the same thing.
Select or touch pad.
Ah!
I see, I see.
I'm on my PS5, sorry.
I see, I see, I see.
Increases attack by... Wow!
Power booster!
Might be?
It's okay.
How would you have known?
How would you have known that I was playing on my PS5?
I always forget about the touch pad, I'm not gonna lie.
Because I... What?
What games do I use it in?
Not even in Astro Bot!
We gotta play the new Astro Bot DLC.
Forgot the items existed.
It can't be!
You mean an Autobot ship is responsible for all the destruction in the city?
It appears so, Wheeljack.
But I doubt it was an Autobot hand that caused the destruction.
Another Cybertronian ship crashed on Earth?
What are the odds?
The colonnade is comprised of the essential aspects of our lost Cybertronian heritage.
And it was placed inside the Ferotaxis.
The supercomputer that controls the Proud Star.
The Ferotaxis literally carries our culture inside of it.
What an historical find that would be!
So much art and beauty and history has been lost to find it again.
So much art and beauty.
The Ferotaxis controls both the Plasma Core and the Insecticons.
It directs the power and gives the Insecticons their function and purpose.
Ok, so we find the Ferotaxis and what?
Destroy it?
It's got so much of our culture in it.
We can't do that, can we?
Our culture!
No, we can't.
We find the Plasma Core and shut it down.
Shutting down the power is the most surefire way to stop the cyberforming.
Then we locate the Ferotaxis and preserve our culture.
As Nova Prime intended.
But for now, stay focused.
There are more floors to this ship.
We split up and locate the Plasma Core.
Split up gang!
Alright.
Yeah, where are they going?
Hello.
Oh no?
Ok.
Oh.
Ominous much?
Let's grab this yummy over here.
I like how you can see through the windows.
It looks so cool.
Like you can see through...
Hey!
Little... quit bugging me!
Get it?
Probably too high level of a joke for you guys to understand though.
I know you like it.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Enter the Ark?
Yeah.
Let's enter the Ark!
I'm not smart.
Let's skip.
I want to use this, but only Optimus can.
It sells for a good amount though.
It's probably super slow too.
Lightning sword.
True, true Raiden fashion.
Let's see.
I feel like tech is good to get, right?
Like right now...
We only have two slots, but can we make more slots?
I'm going to try again.
Develop.
Ok.
All in?
All in!
That sounds like something for me, baby!
What did I get?
Wait.
Increases amount health recovers and increases resistance to status effects.
I like our enhanced radar, but...
All in!
We can play blackjack in this?
We got like a nice... It's so rare.
And damage down.
Maybe the status guard one will switch out.
Because melee attack up is good too.
And if we are taking less damage, maybe we don't need to heal more.
Ok.
I'm feeling lucky.
I shouldn't feel lucky.
I wish I get a refund.
Guys, I got to go to the little ghost's room real quick.
Oh, no.
That's not.
Sorry.
Ready, ready, ready.
One second.
I'll be just a minute.
Murphy, you're too early.
Sorry about that.
I didn't realize what time it was.
I had to feed my cats too.
It's dinner time.
Alright.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Okey dokey.
Dinner time.
What's for dinner?
A sensitive stomach?
Return to gameplay.
Yes.
Alright.
Let's just go for it.
Did you wash your hands?
I always do.
You don't even have to ask.
I always wash my hands.
Is there anything like around?
Nope.
There is invisible wall.
Die bug.
Starscream 1.
Files.
Info logs.
What is a Cybertronian?
Cybertronians are robotic aliens from the distant planet of Cybertron.
These robots have the ability to alter their shapes, changing modes into vehicles.
Each Cybertronian, with rare exceptions, can take on one alternate mode.
As far back as many as their memories stretch, two distinct factions of Cybertronians have been locked in a constant and terrible war.
Thanks for the super chat you guys.
Thank you.
Megatron.
It is apparent that neither Megatron nor his Decepticon lieutenants knew for certain what was happening to the city, nor what lies beneath it.
However, Megatron's memory of the Golden Age is clearer than most Cybertronians.
And so it appears that he suspected that plasma energy was one of the causes of the city's destruction.
Megatron's suspicions were confirmed.
The ship he now controls is indeed the proud star of legend.
Commentary.
It must be a perverse kind of joy that Megatron now feels.
Knowing that the instrument of Earth's destruction was an Autobot invention and Autobot mission.
What a perverse kind of joy.
At least they're honest about it.
Oh, there's a voice playback.
Indeed, the proud star of legend.
Commentary.
It must be a perverse kind of joy that Megatron now feels.
Knowing that the instrument of Earth's destruction was an Autobot invention and Autobot mission.
Observation.
Starscream's anger, Starscream's constant annoyance with Megatron appears to be heightened.
As is the tension with his fellow Seekers, Thundercracker and Skywarp.
It appears that the recent rise in tensions surrounds the search for the plasma core.
Starscream is perhaps feeling that he is being underused and Thundercracker feeling that plasma energy is too dangerous.
It is likely that Starscream will berate Thundercracker for his apparent cowardice while secretly fearing destruction himself by way of the plasma core.
He's such a little coward.
Starscream, silly guy.
Okay.
We're searching.
We're continuing.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot.
I don't know why I drove right into that.
I'm trying to dodge.
I can't tell what he's saying.
What are you saying?
Oh shoot.
Got him.
Soundwave superior.
Abort mission.
Bye Soundwave!
Silly guy.
Okay.
We go to the plasma core and disable it.
The ferrotoxis has the sum total of Cybertronian culture recorded within.
If at all possible, we must preserve it.
Oh, there's a second one.
Pull triangle then release it fires a drill.
Oh yeah, yeah, the charge up.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, I gotta remember to do that.
Yeah!
Is it above or below?
Oh my gosh, look you can see the Megatron logo.
No, it definitely can't be below.
Weird.
It's my spawn day!
Can you wish me a happy birthday Metal Gear Solid version?
Osu no!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Osu no!
Above?
I don't know.
I mean we did get one here.
Maybe it's bugged.
Oh, this thing.
Some transversal cruisers have short...
You bugged?
A pun?
Not this time.
Ew.
Anything over here?
Nope, this is bugged.
Matara would love this place.
Look, these guys are like moonwalking.
Ew, they're even on the machine!
Starscream 2.
What?
Oh, we'll follow who first on Twitter.
Not me.
Those butts!
Regulate it to those butts!
I don't know who I just...
Anyway...
Oh...
They gotta be kidding with that.
Oh, we got our stats up.
Cool.
Chill out, bug.
Quit bugging out.
Oh gosh, there's more?
He's
already dead, but I can at least...
Oh, there's some health over here.
Yeah!
Okay, we got our goods.
We got the loot.
My goods!
Nice.
Oh shoot!
Oh come on!
Come on!
He's too...
He's too nimble.
Ouch!
I'm trying
to get my stuff.
I earned it!
I earned my loot!
Oh, so close with this guy.
Nice.
Alright.
I think there's...
Please!
Oh my god, I can barely reach him.
Maybe I should have switched to the long swords.
Can I have the stuff that's on the ground?
Over there!
Go grab it!
Over here!
Grab it.
Nice.
I think that's...
All of it.
Get the loot!
We get the loot!
Now that's everything.
Soundwave's VA is Frank Welker.
AKA the guy who voiced Freddy in most of Scooby-Doo.
Since the original... Oh my gosh.
Freddy!
That guy...
That guy's so silly.
Hold on.
Oh, I thought we could... Wait.
I thought for a second we could go in there.
No!
It's just within our... Just beyond our grasp.
Freddy is Frank's natural voice too?
That's great.
Is this a puzzle?
What is this part actually?
Enter?
No, I think I'm okay right now.
With the side mission.
I like it in here.
I want to keep going.
Run!
Oh gosh, it's all time!
Oh my gosh.
No!
I missed it at the last second.
We'll be visiting Japan in May.
Thanks for the mileage recommendation.
My wife is a big Steins Gate fan.
I hope you enjoy it.
The cafe is not usually ever that busy so...
It's usually pretty easy to get the seat where they sit at and everything too.
Oh my gosh, that other one is such a red herring.
Seriously?
Oh wow, this is...
I could have gone better.
Them I-frames.
Thank goodness for them.
Who is still blasting?
Oh, he's in there somewhere.
Oh, there he is.
I got him.
Wow, they are all in here!
Bad news!
OK.
Am I in the wrong area?
Warning!
Of course I...
Wait, am I going the right way?
Is this the way you want me to go?
What is this?
How mysterious.
Go, go, go!
Go, Bubbly!
Oh, we totally missed it.
Now I'm back on the bottom floor.
Oh, it's side stuff.
Shoot.
I think that's where actually the...
What's it called?
The little area where I can...
See the hidden...
Whatever it's called.
The orange thing on the map.
What else is down here though?
I'm just curious.
Or maybe we can get to it from here.
Nope.
OK.
Turn around.
What?
It's so tepid.
Alright!
Thought this game got delisted.
Yeah, I got it.
But it wasn't delisted.
I mean, maybe you could find...
I wonder if you found like...
Well, probably it would be so expensive if you found like a physical copy...
At like a...
What's it called?
A used game store or something.
Those kinds of places would probably...
Hike it up.
But you know how like...
Like places that sell used...
Like used books and stuff too.
But they also sometimes sell used...
Games?
Actually...
I went to one of those places...
And that's actually where I found...
My...
MGS4 RISK.
So it's totally worth checking those places.
Hi, it's me!
Thanks for the 20 Gets!
Are you gonna try out War for Cybertron?
And follow Cybertron after Deprestation?
Maybe.
I don't know yet.
I haven't really thought about it.
Oh, why did I do that?
No!
We were right there!
Do I try one more time?
Or do we give up?
Needed more speed.
I know.
Yeah, there's no boostering.
One more?
Okay, one more.
One more, one more, one more.
Maybe if I...
Let's try this.
Look!
See, even though I got it...
It's still listed as...
That I have it.
That's so strange.
No, baby!
These look like the...
Hmm, okay.
Wow, there's tons of stuff over here.
What the hell?
There's tons of lot...loot.
There's lots of loot.
Tons of lots.
Wow!
There's so much stuff over here!
Let's go!
Tons of lot.
I thought it would be like a side quest, but no.
What is that?
Shiny.
Looks yummy.
How would I get to that?
You gotta shoot it?
No?
It looks like a grabable.
Looks like something you should...
She's a loot brand.
I know, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for my condition.
Oh, wait.
I wonder though if we can get to it from here.
No, we're too small.
Anyway.
It's fine.
Does anyone know what it's for though?
So itty bitty.
Oh, it's art.
Okay.
I didn't know what was gonna open up.
And then...
Here.
Come on, I still didn't even make it.
Let me in.
This is the boss for me.
Let me in, please.
Why do I keep...
I take damage no matter what.
I gotta keep going, right?
They're just like, don't fight it on your own.
Keep going.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to scream like that.
Can I use this?
How do I use it, actually?
Thank you.
Let
me grab my stuff first.
Please, let me grab my loot.
Oh my gosh.
I just barely dodged that.
Nice.
Oh, we got a thing on shockwave.
Cool.
Game over.
Who else wants to mess with me?
It's pretty chill.
We're searching?
That's not chill.
That is convenient.
I love Touhou.
Oh my god.
They gave me such sweet loot though.
They're still going?
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh no, no, no, no.
They're sending me their big blue balls.
What are those?
Nice.
I got an S rank.
Hey, I made it.
Why would you say that, Bumblebee?
You jinxed yourself.
Hey, I made it.
Scrapna.
Ancient.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Shit.
Oh my gosh, I can't dodge worth shit.
Oh, I'm gonna die here for real.
I can't see anything.
I'm gonna
die.
I'm gonna die for sure.
Oh gosh, I'm trying to dodge, but I get stuck in a stunlock loop.
Well, I don't have anything to really kill you with.
Use my ult?
I forgot about it.
So true.
We don't wanna die.
No, don't die on us.
Supposed to be shrapnel, but Hasbro lost the trademark.
That's... no way.
Find the plasma core.
I'm almost dead.
Maybe I should have died just so I can get my health back.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
I'm searching.
Dying is for cowards.
I don't wanna use my healing items.
Unless I'm in a fight, like a boss fight or something.
We don't know when things will get really tough, you guys.
Even though I'm on scout...
I'm looting a little bit.
My health is... my screen is flashing.
Ah...
What is this area?
Why are you so mysterious?
How is shrapnel a copyright?
When it's literally an actual word.
That shouldn't be allowed.
Bombshell.
I'm so dead.
It's OK.
I think this is the checkpoint.
Oh my gosh!
He was on top of me!
Nice.
Back attack!
Oh wait, where is the back shot?
Where is the back...
Nevermind.
Where is my back attack?
What happened to it?
The what?
Oh, what did I say?
What did I say?
I said where is my back attack.
Oh oh, there is some craziness going on up in there.
You said back shot.
No, I said back attack!
Why does it keep saying that there is more?
Mysterious.
I said it though!
Maybe I didn't.
I don't know.
Whatever.
Let's get through!
These freaking doors are the pain of my existence.
Can I just destroy this door?
Wow, that makes me feel special.
Oh shoot, that's not what I meant to do!
That's not what I meant to do.
I meant to dodge.
Oopsie.
Um...
Okay, we made it.
Oh, you can see when it saves.
I just noticed at the bottom.
That's quite nice.
Sneaky.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm here.
Where is the next part?
Oh, down here?
Oh my gosh, how did I make it?
I'm too good.
I'm good!
If only I were as chill as this guy.
The part that says something different depending on who you play as.
Goldfire or Goldbug copyright.
SB's upgraded form in season 3 of the cartoon.
Thank you guys for all the lore.
I do appreciate it.
Especially because, you know, I don't know a lot of stuff about...
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
Oh, Bumblebee.
You're so good.
Why are you doing that?
We made it!
Can I get a save point?
Can I get a checkpoint?
Can I get a checkpoint in the chat?
Why are they so...
Checkpoint!
I am being educated in the lore myself.
My fig is...
Wow.
That sounds pretty precise.
Proud Star 3.
I like how they are like...
You want to like update...
You want to like...
You want to like fix yourself up a little bit first?
Before you go in there, huh?
You want to do that, buddy?
We didn't get much good stuff.
Totally not a boss arena.
I know we can play as Wheeljack.
I like Bumblebee.
What should
we do?
What's some new moves we can get?
Burnout?
Vehicle mode and not moving.
Hold O to start a burnout.
Interesting.
Rush combo.
Parry.
Parry the platypus.
Find achieving focus.
Hold square or triangle or L2 to perform a vicious counterattack.
Spin attack.
Rotate L 360 degrees and triangle.
These are some real fighting game moves.
Powerful shove that puts enemies off balance.
Quickly tilt the movement button back then forward.
Probably just like that.
Or we could keep doing gacha.
When are we going to unlock the stuff that's like...
Look at this.
This is 180,000 points but it's still rank C.
Is that because of the level or like just how good it is?
Let's go gambling.
Bayonetta with robots.
I did not play Bayonetta so I apologize.
Just as it lands.
I'm always pushing the movement button though.
I could get it still.
What is focus?
Is that when I dodge correctly and then...
That's when I dodge and I go into slow-mo, right?
Yeah?
Still safe is good.
Dodge an enemy's attacks at just the right moment to induce focus.
Press R1 just as you are hit.
So if I get hit and I press R1 really...
That one is actually...
Because so often I'm just like... I pressed dodge.
Maybe that one would be good.
Extra dodge frames.
Yeah.
I'm going to get that one.
Nice.
And then we could sell some stuff.
Maybe we could make...
What the heck?
I thought that... It didn't look like a fist at a glance.
It looked like...
Something else.
I don't want to sell that.
Wait, I want to equip the...
Weapons?
I think we could equip...
Let's see.
Wait, what's better?
The drills or... Let's see.
No.
Maybe it's better than the swords though.
Like what?
It looked like...
Like a hole.
Like a booty hole.
OK, I'll say it.
It looked like a booty hole.
OK.
Are you happy now?
One of my friends the other day was just like...
You should do like a live stream of your cats, you know?
Like...
You should do a live stream where your cats are just on the camera and they're just like...
Chilling and, you know, relaxing.
Especially Paws since people haven't seen her so much.
And I was like...
I was like...
Yeah, but she doesn't do anything.
Like, actually, she is constantly cleaning herself and...
I was like, nobody wants to watch her lick her booty hole.
Like, that's all she does all day.
She's just...
I just don't...
I don't think everybody wants to watch that.
Says you.
She's just like me.
Tiara?
Girl?
As a cat owner, I think it's cute.
She's also just all over the place.
I don't think I would be able to...
Keep her...
Actually...
I don't know, maybe if she laid in her bed.
She has a bed in my room, so...
She's a very clean cat.
It would be great if I could get her and Butaro licking each other.
And then...
Also fighting each other.
Because they do that thing where they lick, lick, lick.
Fight, fight, fight.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, that's a great question.
I'm just yapping, sorry.
Oh, I want to... I want to sit and...
I want to develop some tech.
I love the gacha.
But I wish I could have more equipment spots.
Is that something that I can...
Like, upgrade somehow?
Like, Optimus Prime gets three...
Ready, ready, ready.
Upgrade stats.
But that I can only do in battle, right?
I imagine.
Oh, look at this!
This one is so close.
Add EXP.
Wait, no, it's really far away.
Split screen.
Cats on top, you play MGS on the bottom.
That'd be great.
Just Prime.
We need to rank up the last one.
This one?
But we need to get it, like...
All the way... So, look at this.
Watch.
It only...
Oh wait, it did go up one rank.
Oh...
Boo.
Chatamus Prime.
I like Bumblebee.
Watching your stream while browsing for a yummy merch to buy.
What kind of merch are you looking for?
The stats are also a reference to the stats printed on the box of each of the original toys.
Stop!
This game is so in-depth, so detailed.
Let's see how we do on the boss.
Did I switch out the weapons or anything?
I don't think so.
Let's...
I'm gonna synthesize my gloves.
I'm gonna synthesize... Where are the...
Where are they?
Oh, the drills, yeah.
Synthesize...
I'll just use, like...
Oh, but it costs a lot of money.
Oh, but that goes up pretty high.
Synthesizing.
I'm gonna keep going.
I'm gonna level it up to level 6 at least.
I like the drills.
Oh, interesting.
What?
Oh, skills to be transferred?
Health recovery up.
Increases the recovery rate by the ultimate gauge by 8%.
Increases the amount of health recovered by 6%.
Increases weapon energy recovery item drop rate by 15%.
Oh, neat!
All in shuts off healing.
It did?
Boy, it did.
What did it do?
Hold on.
Oh, increases attack at the cost of losing ability to recover.
No wonder I've been taking so much...
Like, my health has been so much lower.
I thought the game was just getting harder.
You don't need to heal if you don't get hit.
We did just buy that new skill, right?
Okay, I'm gonna develop one more time.
We might get lucky.
We might get lucky!
What?
All in again?
Damage down.
What was the other one we got?
Ultimate move attack up.
I like the damage down better.
Especially if we are not able to heal.
It's a sign.
You know what?
Let's just try it.
If we wanna come back, we can.
Do they stack?
I don't know.
Here we go!
I like this stage a whole lot.
The fact that the ground is kind of bouncy.
Eww...
Kick
back!
Shoot, he's fast.
Oh my gosh!
Phase 2!
Oh, that's not good.
Really?
Oh my god, no way.
Oh my gosh, they're crazy.
Scary.
Scary, scary, scary.
Oh my god, oh my god.
All three of them at once.
Oh my gosh!
Screw it, just attack!
Oh my god, I don't know who to attack.
Let's go.
Oh shoot, I meant to...
I meant to dodge.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Run!
No!
Why am I not using the drills?
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can I leave?
Hey!
You!
Nice!
Alright!
Alright.
He's so zippy.
I know, I love it!
Ok!
Pull it out!
Ok, stop acting so nonchalant.
Please, don't give up already.
Almost through!
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot.
Where did these guys come from?
Just ignore them.
Nice.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, wait, what do you mean?
Oh gosh, I have a time limit!
I just noticed the time limit.
Ok, alright, alright, alright.
Oh, we did it.
Easy peasy.
It will explode.
This guy is the same guy I actually play.
One of my favorite childhood games.
You get the chance to try Warper's Cybercharm and follow Cybercharm's music.
I will try to play them.
Sorry, my contacts are killing me today.
Ok!
Sorry, hold on, my eye drops.
Oh...
I don't know why my eyes are stinging so much today.
Oh, I got a blip!
I don't know why my eyes are stinging.
I might have to call it done.
I wanted to get at least halfway.
Well, halfway would have been...
Chapter 4, but...
2 out of 7.
Maybe...
Later this week I can just kind of...
If I'm taking... I'm usually pretty slow with games because I like to run around and I like to yap and I like to explore and stuff.
So maybe later this week we can...
I could just endurance it or something and we can finish it up.
Probably wouldn't be so much of an endurance.
Probably like... I don't know.
I consider like 6 hours an endurance kind of way, you know?
But it's so fun!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry princess, thank you!
Sorry guys, I would play more, but I actually...
My contacts today are just going crazy.
Transformers movie watch along?
I do want to watch it before we continue playing.
I will try and...
My schedule is...
Maybe this is a Transformers week.
It is a Transformers week maybe.
But I also have to finish...
I have to finish Lifeline 2.
Hot dog!
Hot dog indeed!
Highly recommend the basics by Chris McFeely on YouTube.
10 to 15 minute videos that cover everything.
It's a lord of biology!
Thank you, K-1!
I'm in for Transformers week.
I'm trying to figure out if I have enough time to like have a watch along and have...
If I don't do a watch along this week, we can definitely do it.
Well...
Maybe before I go to Japan.
I
do want to kind of...
Since I'm in mid-play, I would like to watch the movie.
So I can understand more about the characters and the lore, you know what I mean?
I think that would be fun.
Great job, Miki-chan!
I've been trapped at home in a snowstorm!
It was really fun to watch you play!
Stay warm!
Stay warm, stay warm.
Will I be getting the figures in the future?
It depends.
Do I have space for another collection?
No.
Will that stop me?
Who knows.
Will I maybe get the Kotobukiya...
Have you guys seen those Kotobukiya Bishoujo figures?
Casio, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
They have like Optimus and Megatron versions.
I don't know if they made anyone else though.
But I could at least get those.
Kotobukiya Bishoujo...
Oh, Transformers!
Oh my gosh, my phone is listening to me.
Oh wait, they made a Bumblebee it looks like.
Who is this?
It's not saying to me.
Oh, Thundercracker!
They made a Thundercracker one too.
Last year, actually.
The Optimus one is so cute.
Oh my goodness, I love her little hair buns.
If you've ever seen them.
They made Starscream and the Seekers.
They made way more than I thought they did.
Thumbnail art was actually based loosely off the Bumblebee outfit as well.
I love Bumblebee.
But yeah, we'll do more Transformers.
We will, we will.
Sorry about my eyes, guys.
I'm so sorry.
But yeah, I hope you had fun.
This game is so...
So much fun to play.
I feel so bad that it's delisted.
So that more people can't play it.
Impact, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
I feel like model kits.
The Bloki's TF1 Optimus and Megatron are really good.
$50 each?
Wow, that's so cheap.
You don't need any tools.
I'm not a super model kit person because I'm too much of a perfectionist.
I don't have time to learn...
I want to paint them, right?
But I don't have time to learn how to paint so well.
To my standards.
So, I'm like...
It's the same with garage kits and figures and stuff too.
Small blaster.
Grimlock!
Grimlock.
All he does is grunt.
I love me a character that grunts.
Let's see.
Only one slot!
Grimlock!
They're nerfing you!
Mint with her eyes bleeding out.
They're not bleeding out.
I don't know why they're so dry today.
Maybe because I woke up early.
Maybe just because I slept bad.
I don't know.
Being a ghost is hard.
I gotta keep my ectoplasm properly hydrated.
Could be the weather.
It could be.
I did go outside and I don't like doing that.
I don't like doing that!
But anyways, I hope you guys had fun!
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
Have a good morning, day, evening, night, whatever time it is for you!
And I'll see you when I see you!
See you!
Otsumito!
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Thank you for today too!
Bye bye!
Otsumito!
Oh my god, you guys.
Sorry to interrupt, but I just went to the art gallery and look at this visual!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, it's so awesome!
Sorry.
Wow!
Wait, I want to use this as my thumbnail.
Excuse me?
Excuse you guys too?
Thumbnail art?
Or this one?
No, we can't use this one.
Look at him!
Why does it look like his gun has a suppressor on it?
Wow!
Generations art.
He's just a truck.
Oh my god, the guy is dead on the ground.
Crazy.
Okay, bye!